AGENDA.
ONCE HE MAKES HIS DECISION
FINAL.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
FOR REACTION I TALKED TO
REPUBLICAN SENATOR BOB
CORKER OF TENNESSEE JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO.
SENATOR CORKER, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
THANKS FOR FIRST TIME ON THE
>> A LITTLE LATE.
>> Laura: I KNOW WE KEPT YOU
UP.
BIG NEWS DAY, DID THIS
REALLY SURPRISE YOU, REX
TILLERSON OUT BY THE
PRESIDENT?
DID YOU EVER THINK HE WAS A
GREAT FIT?
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS REALLY
GOOD AT GIVING SOUND ADVICE.
I HAVE KNOWN FOR SOME
TIME -- I TALK TO BOTH OF
THEM OFTEN.
I KNOW IT HASN'T BEEN A
PERFECT FIT.
WAS I SURPRISED?
NOT REALLY.
BUT, I WILL SAY SINCE
DECEMBER 1st, RIGHT AROUND
THAT TIME, YOU FELT A
REPRIEVE.
YOU FELT LIKE THAT THEY WERE
WORKING BETTER TOGETHER.
WAS THIS IS CHAOS.
PEOPLE ARE FREAKING OUT IN
THE MEDIA.
JUST MORE CHAOS.
AND IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS APPARENTLY
CONSIDERING ALSO FIRING THE
V.A. SECRETARY AFTER THE
STORY BROKE THAT HE WAS ON
SOME SIGHTSEEING TRIP I
GUESS IN EUROPE ON OFFICIAL
BUSINESS.
SHULKIN MIGHT BE OUT
REPLACED BY RICK PERRY.
THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I THINK RICK WILL BE GOOD
AT ANYTHING HE DOES.
HE HAS BEEN A GOOD GOVERNOR,
OBVIOUSLY.
LOOK, THIS IS AS I WAS
TELLING YOU EARLIER, THE
REPORTERS IN THE HALLWAY
HAVE ALMOST BECOME THIS IS
JUST SORT OF NORMAL AND
CHANGES ARE OCCURRING.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS SOMEONE AS SECRETARY
OF STATE THAT HE HAS A LOT
OF FAITH IN.
AND, AGAIN, I THOUGHT REX
DID A VERY GOOD JOB.
HE HAS A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH MATTIS, WHICH IS VERY
UNUSUAL.
AND THE TWO OF THEM ALWAYS
GO IN ON THE SAME PAGE.
AND I DON'T KNOW POMPEO VERY
WELL.
BUT I DO HEAR VERY GOOD
THINGS ABOUT HIM AND LOOK
FORWARD.
HE'S GOING TO BE IN THE
OFFICE LATER THIS WEEK.
I LOOK FORWARD TO A GOOD
CONFIRMATION.
>> Laura: THE THOUGHT IS THE
INTERNATIONALISTS, THE
INTERVENTIONISTS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE KIND OF
ON THE DOWN SLIDE AND THE
MORE NATIONALISTS POPULIST
WING IS ON THE ASCENDANCY
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, POMPEO
IS MORE IN LINE WITH TRUMP.
TILLERSON IS MORE, I THINK
MORE IN LINE WITH YOUR
THINKING AND WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT?
IS IT BETTER TO HAVE THAT
TENSION WHERE THE
INTERNATIONALISTS ARE KIND
OF VYING FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
EAR?
>> I WOULD USE THE WORLD
REALIST.
>> Laura: OKAY, FINE.
YOU WILL USE YOUR
TERMINOLOGY I WILL USE MINE.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH
WHICH WE CLAWED.
I WAS ONE OF THE FIRST TO
LAUD ONE OF HIS FOREIGN
POLICY SPEECH HAD THE
MAKINGS OF A JIM BAKER
REALIST WORLD.
I DON'T NECESSARILY LOOK AT
HIM AS A NATIONALIST.
I MEAN, HE IS IN AFGHANISTAN
DOING WHAT HE IS DOING AND
COMMITTED TO NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS DIVINE BY TIME AND
SO HE IS A MIX.
HE IS MORE OF A REALIST.
I DO THINK IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
COUNTERING VOICES.
>> Laura: AND THE PRESIDENT
DOES AS WELL.
>> HE ACTUALLY LIKES HEARING
THE DEBATE.
HE TALKED ABOUT THAT A GREAT
DEAL IN THE GARY COHN WHEN
HE LEFT.
SO, LOOK, I THINK THAT AS
LONG AS WHOEVER IS WORKING
WITH HIM, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THEIR POINT OF VIEW IS, IS
GIVING HIM THE FULL COLLAGE
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO THINK
ABOUT THINGS, THEN I THINK
THAT'S FINE.
>> Laura: TILLERSON COULDN'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION DID HE
CALL HIM A MORON.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK
WELL.
REMEMBER, BARACK OBAMA FIRED
ONLY A FEW PEOPLE.
MCCHRYSTAL, FIRED MATTIS.
REMEMBER WHEN HE FIRED
MATTIS HE DIDN'T EACH TELL
HIM.
MATTIS LEARNED ABOUT IT, I
GUESS SECOND HAND OR THIRD
HAND.
PEOPLE SWITCH UP POSITIONS
WHEN THE CHEMISTRY ISN'T
RIGHT.
>> THE PRESIDENT CALLED THIS
MORNING ON HIS WAY OUT WEST
ABOUT 10:00 FROM AIR FORCE
ONE.
EVERY ONE OF THESE PEOPLE
SERVE AT HIS PLEASURE.
IT'S HIS DECISION.
>> NEW CIA CHIEF WOULD BE
GINA HASPEL WHO WILL BE WITH
THE CIA 30 YEARS.
FIRST WOMAN TO EVER HEAD
THAT AGENCY.
SHE IS NOT GOING WITHOUT
CRITICISM TODAY.
THIS IS A FORMER FBI SPECIAL
AGENT ALLI WHO WAS ON MSNBC
EARLIER TODAY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THERE IS THE ISSUE OF
TORTURE.
ALSO THERE IS THE ISSUE OF
DESTRUCTION OF VIDEOTAPES.
EVIDENCE OF TORTURE.
THAT HAPPENED IN VIOLATION
OF A FEDERAL JUDGE'S ORDER.
SO NOW THIS IS ANOTHER THING
THAT NEED TO COME OUT DURING
THE CONFIRMATION HEARING.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT SHE
THINKS ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
>> Laura: THE LEFT IS
GEARING UP TO GO AFTER GINA
HASPEL WHO IS UNDERCOVER FOR
MOST OF HER CAREER IS BEING
LAUDED EVEN BY SOME FORMER
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS I THINK CLAPPER
TODAY.
WHAT OF THAT?
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO
SEE WITH THESE CHANGES,
MAYBE THREE OF THEM, YOU
MENTIONED ONE I WAS UNAWARE
OF EARLIER PROBABLY LIKELY
TO SEE A PRETTY PARTISAN
ENVIRONMENT OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS.
>> Laura: WE HAVE AN ARTICLE
TODAY OUT ABOUT HOW THE NEW
OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL MIGHT
NOT DEFUND SANCTUARY CITIES.
I SAW THAT TODAY AND I
THOUGHT WAIT A SECOND, NOW
WE HAVE GOT THE HOUSE AND
SENATE IN REPUBLICAN HANDS.
WE GOT A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICANS AT ELECTION TIME
ARE REALLY BIG ON DEFUNDING
THINGS.
WE ARE GOING TO DO THIS AND
TAKE THE MONEY FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND DEFUND
SANCTUARY CITIES.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THEY MIGHT
NOT DO THAT WHAT PLANET AM I
LIVING ON.
WHAT IS YOUR VIEW ON THE
SANCTUARY CITY ISSUE?
THE PRESIDENT IS OUT IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD FOLLOW
THROUGH ON DEFUNDING THEM.
THIS IS DECISION MADE BY
MCCONNELL, RYAN, SCHUMER AND
PELOSI, OKAY?
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
THE FINAL DECIDERS.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S IN THE
OMNI.
>> Laura: THAT'S A PROBLEM,
TOO.
NO ONE KNOWS WHAT'S IN IT
APPARENTLY.
>> THE HOUSE MAY VOTE ON IT
THIS FRIDAY.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE IT
UP NEXT WEEK.
REGARDING
REGARDLEG
REGARDLESS OF THE DEFUNDING
WHICH I HOPE OCCURS IT'S GOD
AWFUL AMOUNT OF MONEY.
WE ARE SPENDING $2 TRILLION
MORE OVER THE NEXT DECADE IF
WE GO THROUGH WITH THIS
PROCESS, WHICH WE ARE.
SO, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE OUGHT TO BE ALARMED
BY THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
SPENDING THAT'S IN THIS BILL
AND WE OUGHT TO DEFUND
SANCTUARY CITIES.
>> Laura: YOU WERE CLOSE FOR
NOT VOTING FOR THAT TAX
BILL.
>> I WAS.
>> Laura: BECAUSE IT WASN'T
WHAT A LOT OF US WANTED IN A
TAX BILL BUT NEVERTHELESS IT
DOES SEEM LIKE THE ECONOMY
AND A LOT OF SPENDING.
ANY REGRETS THERE.
>> LOOK, I HAVE BEEN A
DEFICIT HAWK MY ENTIRE TIME.
I JUST ALOUDED TO THAT NOW.
I HAVE ALSO BEEN A
PRO-GROWTH TAX PERSON.
SO YOU END UP IN THIS PLACE,
YOU KNOW, NOTHING IS PERFECT
HERE.
IT WAS ABOUT HALF A TRILLION
DOLLARS OFF ON A 43
TRILLION-DOLLAR BASE,
SOMETHING I DIDN'T WANT TO
SEE HAPPEN.
BUFF AT THE END OF THE DAY,
I'M GLAD THE ECONOMY IS
GROWING AND I'M GLAD THAT
BUSINESSES ARE HIRING PEOPLE
AND WAGES ARE GOING UP.
>> Laura: MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, WHERE DO YOU
THINK THIS IS GOING TO END
UP?
PEOPLE SAY TRUMP IS NOT
TOUGH ON RUSSIA LIKE HE
SHOULD BE.
I LIKE AT OBAMA.
RUSSIA ROLLED INTO CRIMIA,
THEY WERE DOING THE RESET,
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
>> RIGHT.
>> Laura: DIDN'T SEEM LIKE
RUSSIA WAS DETERRED AT ALL
DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
A LOT OF --
>> -- WE TRIED TO GET LETHAL
DEFENSIVE WEAPONS IN THE
UKRAINE.
WE COULDN'T DO IT.
WE PASSED A BILL TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
ENOUGH TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS SENDING
THOSE LETHAL WEAPON ITEMS
IN.
SO, LOOK, I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND I HEARD
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPEAK UP
TODAY ABOUT THE KILLING OF
THE SPY IN U.K.
SO I THINK THE RHETORIC FROM
HIM IS GETTING STRONGER.
CERTAINLY CORRECT ME IF I AM
WRONG ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE HAS BEEN PUSHING BACK
AND, LOOK, RUSSIA IS A
PROBLEM AND THEY ARE GOING
TO BE A PROBLEM LIKELY IN
OUR ELECTION.
>> Laura: WHO IS A BIGGER
PROBLEM CHINA OR RUSSIA, THE
SIZE OF THE MILITARY.
>> HAS THE SIZE OF ITALY.
THERE
♪ MUCH THERE BUT THEY HAVE
NUCLEAR ARMAMENTS.
IMMEDIATELY THE ISSUE IS
MORE ACUTE WITH RUSSIA
BECAUSE THEY TRY TO STOP ALL
THAT WE ARE DOING.
THEY TRY TO INTERFERE.